so
the so this has developed like where
like okay
uh it was also seen the drug discovery
scenario from a serendipity to a
rational drug design
where we were looking at like to doing a
docking today we can dock
billions of compounds in few days even
like molecular dynamics which takes like
probably weeks and months today can be
done in
a day or two with good gpu cards
the thermodynamics free energy
perturbation etc
which were like taking about three to
six months kind of things three can be
done in four to six hours
which are much much accuracy of about
like 0.5 to 0.6 kilo calorie
so these are the great advances like
what is happening
today but at the same time if you see on
the academic front like
uh are the academic syllabuses whether
they cover all these things
absolutely no right like there is even
today like okay there is not even
anybody is offering a course on
computational drug design
there is like okay last two years back
like computational biology was started
in few of the universities
it's good like these some of the pine
bio and other groups are
joining together and offering uh the
webinars courses like these things and
i'm happy to see so many of you like
participating in this
we are also very happy to be part of
this event uh
to give you some insights about the
development part of it coming to
schroedinger we are a 30 year old
company started with the vision of
doing computational drug design uh by
deisha
then later than like a lot of great
visionaries like bill gates google
everybody join
today we are not only just a software
developer we are also into our own drug
discovery
where do we do lot of collaborative drug
discovery
and we are also into our own drug
discovery we have speeded up the drug
discovery in a much much faster way than
anybody expected
probably even five years back uh we have
very good success stories probably you
can go and see in our websites
where we have developed a molecule for
acc
within a span of nine months and sold
for 1.2 billion
we recently signed deal with bms for
about 2.7 billion dollar
for drug discovery and there are so many
drug discovery programs
which we are advancing in a much much
unimaginable faster way
we are today like earlier it used to
take about 10 years to identify a
molecule
and optimize it today we do it in just
about 6 months to 9 months
so that is a phenomenal development
because of the development in the
algorithms development in the docking
methodologies
development of the force fields
development of the free energy
perturbation
understanding the water thermodynamics
and how they play
a role in the real world drug discovery
so there is a phenomenal development
happening
in this particular space in fact like
this is a an
upcoming disruptive technology i'm happy
most of you are joining here
without taking much time i'll ask my
colleagues to take on
the sessions in fact like we have a
whole lot of topics which we are going
to cover
probably first today like they are going
to cover on little bit of an
introduction part of it
going further like okay we will be
talking on other areas on the structure
based drug design
biologics design the free energy
perturbation and with case studies etc
hope you'll all enjoy it like if anybody
wants to feel free to ask questions to
know all my scientists who are all going
to be
in participating in this event thanks a
lot for the organizers for giving me
this opportunity wish you all the very
best thank you
thank you so much mr raghu now i would
want to invite dr
prajwal nandikal dr prajwal nandhikar
received his masters and phd from
naibar mohali national institute of
pharmaceutical sciences education and
research
in 2010 and 15 his research interests
are computer aided drug designing
quantum chemistry and multiscale
molecular dynamics simulation
and he holds 36 publications to his
credit
over to you dr prajwal
yes uh thank you very much sonalika for
the introduction
and thank you very much for giving me an
opportunity to
present something about schrodinger
which is a really exciting
software suit which has many things
to do in in the field of computer aided
revision
and i hope at the end of this
presentation
everybody will get to know about uh more
about schrodinger's suit
and what are the things which are
present with the schrodinger software
and what are the things which you can do
actually
so this is what uh i would like to say
so before starting the presentation uh
i would like to tell you one thing that
i am going to cover mostly on
the software aspect of linger suit
including little bit basics of computer
editor designing and in general truck
designing and
finally i will also touch up upon the
case study like
how efficiently one can use software
to get the best result out of it and
truly uh said by mr raghu in the
short introduction like there were a few
case studies by schrodinger itself
even as a software company we have our
own drug discovery group
and that works on some critical problems
in drug discovery and we got success
actually
and i will briefly touch upon it but
but in detail like we will see it in uh
upcoming presentations what it is about
but i will just
touch it touch it upon various topics
so i hope at the end you will like it so
before starting the presentation
um so can anybody please confirm
sonalika whether
the screen is visible and my voice is
yes so your screen is visible sir
okay great so yep so
i would like to start from uh instead of
just
starting the presentation here is my
email id
so even uh you can note it down and in
case of any queries or if
questions are not addressed here in this
particular presentation or if you want
to consult us
further do not hesitate to write me back
so i'll be always happy to help you out
and provide the suggestions so please
be in touch and please feel free to
write me
so with this uh like i will be mostly uh
focusing on how one can transform the
drug discovery
using computational modeling and i would
say more
advanced methods of computational
modeling so most of the time you have
heard of molecular talking but there is
uh
there is a lot more in the field of
computer aided drug designing and this
is what we are going to see
now so if you uh talk a little bit about
uh
if you know about drug designing so or
how how do like drug gets developed or
how it binds to the receptor so
basically if you go
really uh into the basics uh
you for every drug like it must have
some
target where it gets bind and show some
pharmacological action
so this all resembles to the like local
key model
in very simplistic way you have a lock
you have a key
and then your key fits into lock it
when you move your key it induces
something some changes inside the lock
we call it as a conformational changes
and somehow it change the internal
structure of lock
and your lock gets open or it gets close
so for that what is important thing is
first of all like those conformational
changes which are happening inside the
lock
and the key which by using that
thing we can make those conformational
changes and
we need to know that thing like key is
very much specific to lock so not every
key
fits in every lock so your key and lock
combination is very much unique
and now let's come to the biology and if
you see like
there are many such keys are available
in the world
but for your lock with just a single key
which works very fine
so see same way there are many chemicals
which are available
in the chemical space and its number is
10 to the power 60
that many huge number of possible
chemicals are available
but for the particular receptor or for
particular
so in our case in our body the receptor
is nothing but the protein it can be dna
from the rna
so it's a biological molecule so for
that
particular protein you have a particular
key and
whole idea of drug designing is to find
that particular key which fits
best in your log means that particular
protein
so so there are various ways to find out
that key
which fits particularly inside the lock
but
as uh told by mr raghu that before it
was a serendipity like
people used to try many keys and out of
that maybe they could find one key which
feels better
and such accidental discoveries do
happen just like a blockbuster truck
paracetamol you have like it was
discovered long time back and it is
still working
very fine but there was no uh such a
hardcore research or computer editor
design things were involved in it
but nowadays like uh because of
emergence of this method
so what is uh what do you get because of
those emergence of these computers and
computer editor designing methods is you
will get the microscope
what microscope you will get the
molecular microscope through which
basically you can see the struct
internal structure of log
like how the lock looks like so same way
if you know
the internal structure of logs you know
where are the keys where are the
levers so you can design your key in a
better way
so the same thing is applied to the
receptor you have a protein structure
and if you could see
inside that protein structure what are
the amino acid residues present inside
it what are the functional group present
inside it how it looks like what is
shape of it
then definitely you can design a better
lock a better key
or better molecule again so this is what
the advantage you get it uh because of
computer-related drug designing methods
so we call it as a molecular microscope
because you will be able to see
everything at atomic level detail
and consider schrodinger suit as a
molecular microscope
so it allows you to see what is inside
the
log what is inside the protein structure
and with the help of that you proceed
further with the designing of molecules
so even computer aided drug designing
it's a vast field there are many things
which are involved in it
but overall when we talk about drug
designing it is broadly classified into
structure-based drug designing and
ligand-based drug designing
so here whenever we say structure so
structure resembles to the structure
of receptor in structure of log
structure of protein
so if you have that information
available with you means the structure
of protein then we can go for structure
based methods like
molecular docking molecular dynamics
simulations but
there can be a case when you don't have
information of structure of
your receptor in that case we can also
rely on ligand-based methods like format
for qsar methods or shape-based
screenings
so we are going to see all those methods
there are many such methods which are
available
inside this structure base and
ligand-based methods and we are going to
see it in subsequent sessions
but right now we will mostly try to
understand what it happens actually
so overall like we mostly deal with the
molecular docking process
in which you have a receptor structure
so protein looks like something like
this
it's a huge structure it has particular
shape it has particular volume
it has particular binding pocket and
with the help of software
we try to dock the millions of compound
inside the protein structure
millions of compound with millions of
keys and
out of those millions of key with the
help of molecular docking we generate
various poses calculate their energies
we try to identify a suitable key which
fits better inside the winding pocket
and then we try to further modify that
key using uh
further substitutions on it so in this
way we try to
optimize that lead molecule and we
calculate various parameters like energy
its interaction and based on all those
things
we try to shortlist the best molecule
out of it
and this is the molecule we often take
it further and we go for synthesis and
we check
its biological activity so this is what
the minimum thing which we do in
computer aided drug designing and again
let me tell you this is the minimum
thing which we do
but the sky is again open for you there
are many methods which are available
so before proceeding and for knowing
more methods like it is worth to know
the history of
it like from where it started uh so
maybe many of you are
aware of this history or many of you are
unaware of this history but it is
history is always interesting so it is
better to know it so from where it all
got started so it was started really
long time back
if i remember correctly it's a 1960s
when there was a scientist called martin
carplus like he's still alive
the scientist is still alive and so in
2013
uh if i'm not wrong he got the nobel
prize for his discoveries and
his discovery was developing a force
field so
it all started in that time 1960s
like during his phd he developed force
field and later on he continued with it
so force field was really necessary for
studying those molecules or studying the
structures
as a molecular model so
imagine like in 1960 we started and then
people started working on in mostly in
academics and then it took around
30 years to develop that field and
successfully applied into the field of
drug designing
so the successful example was first
reported by about laboratories and it
was on hiv protease
so they developed hiv proteas inhibitor
using this rational
designing which is help of computers so
this is the first reported study was in
early 1990s so you can imagine like it
took 30 years to develop that field and
actually implementing
it and after that discovery when that
paper got published everybody came to
know like it was a revolution in the
field of drug discovery like
because people got something to see
inside the protein structure that is
what your molecular modeling software is
so the thing is after that like
every pharma company every academic
started using all those softwares
calculated even developing updating that
software and then rest is the history
so there are many such very well known
drug like
you haven't uh you have often heard of
any flu
if you start searching for computer
educator design success story
this was one of the uh starting first
example like
who got success time if you and there
are many such drugs which are
successfully developed through computer
editor designing and
nowadays like every single drug which
you think of like it
passes through the process of computer
editor designing because it is method of
virtual screening the fastest method so
there are many such examples by various
companies
and you can find all those things in a
literature also
so what is basically the power of all
this technique technique of molecular
modeling so
here is the video will deficit the power
of it like
up to what extent one can study the
biological phenomena or physical system
with the help of computers
you really don't need to look at water
in the glass
but you can simply perform molecular
dynamic simulations of water
and different temperatures so let me
tell you the example so this is what the
first left hand side video you can see
it is basically a
molecular dynamic simulation of water so
you have a single water which is present
here
at the middle middle red is oxygen white
is
hydrogen and which is surrounded by
other water molecules and we simulated
it at a
basically room temperature where water
stays at
liquid state and you can see this yellow
dash lines are nothing but the
intermolecular hydrogen bonding which
are happening with the surrounding water
molecules
and if you can carefully see you can see
at any given point this particular
single water molecule is forming
around four hydrogen bonding
interactions with surrounding water
so this is what is the reason why water
stays in a
liquid state at room temperature but now
let's take another example i
increase the temperature again in the
computer see virtually i am doing all
those things
when we increase the temperature up to
the boil boiling point and you can see
when we simulate the
you can suddenly see the water molecule
and the number of hydrogen bondings are
reduced to two or three so at any given
point it is forming two
hydrogen bonding interactions means less
number of hydrogen bonding interaction
and
that prompters uh the software sorry the
water goes into gaseous phase so this is
what well-known phenomena it has
it reduces the intermolecular hydrogen
bonding interaction because of increase
in temperature
and when it happens the state of water
gate changes from
liquid to gaseous phase and you can
capture this
complete phenomena with the help of
computer and the simulation so you
really don't need to look it at a
water place in your
beaker or you don't need to boil it you
can just do it in a computer so this is
what the importance of computer editor
designing
and field of molecular modeling so you
can all simulate everything in the
computer itself so uh other than that
like it is what to know like from where
it started so when
all those things uh started developing
and
you can see like industry started using
it so
it was in the late 90s then when two
scientists came together
professor richard fishner and professor
william godard
from columbia university and california
institute of technology they came
together they were
really imminent scientists in the field
they are still alive
so they are a founder of schrodinger's
software so they started
basically developing this software they
thought okay this is the software
which is the future and then they
started working on the field they
started developing the software each
module one by one
so looking um with the mission with the
single mission of course to improve the
human health and quality of life
by revolutionarizing this particular
drug discovery
and not only drug discovery but one can
use
or you can study various materials also
with the help of computational methods
so this is what their aim was and they
started
uh implementing all those things in the
software and they
started growing it one by one one by one
and now after
like 30 years this is the complete
software suit which we have
which has number of modules present and
across the globe like
as a schrodinger company has grown that
much that across the globe we have
presents at various places mostly our r
d team lies in eastern and western coast
of usa but other than that in uk germany
india and japan also we have office
where we do interact with the scientists
who are using their software
so and then what comes with the
schrodinger suit is there are various
type of
small sub suits which are a part of
complete schrodinger suit
so it can start with the simple way of
visualizing molecule
in the pi mole or if you are working in
case of dnas proteins rnas antibodies
antigens so we have a
tool called biologic suit where all
modules come together to help you to
study
all biological molecules and if you are
interested in drug discovery means small
molecule drug discovery so we have a
special suit for that
which which has all compiled compilation
of
all modules which are necessary for drug
designing
and not only that even for materials if
you want to study materials like
batteries nanoparticles carbon nanotubes
so all those things one can study using
material science suit
you'll be surprised to know that even
isro can use materials and so
they are also using it uh not only isro
but boeing also
so in this way like it has a wide
usage and not only that even discovery
informatics is the small
substitute package which we have which
helps you to analyze the
huge amount of data which is generated
by day-to-day exercise in the field of
chemo informatics
so this is all come together with the
schrodinger suit complete package
so let me introduce those uh package in
a particular way like
in case of small molecule drug discovery
suit which helps you to assist with
the particularly drug discovery process
or
discovery methods so we have various
tools like for example which i have
shown
uh which is most widely used is
protein-like and docking in which one
can perform
molecular talking of huge library of
compounds
in fastest way inside the protein
structure
not only that but in case of general
molecular docking or traditional
molecular docking we consider protein as
a rigid molecule
but with the help of another module
called induced fit docking which is
again part of florida suit
we can also consider the binding pocket
amino acid residues of protein as a
flexible so that it helps you to
understand
the protein structure and its
conformational changes in better way
not only that there are various
ligand-based methods as i said like
pharmaco4 based methods or shape
screening in which
one can use this method to screen the
like uh compounds so for example you
have
active molecule for example paracetamol
so if you want to
look something which looks similar to
paracetamol you can use the
pharmaceutical shape screening
to look for similar type of molecule
from the whole database of billions of
compound
and similarly there is a method called
3dqsar through which one can generate
various contours and understand the
chemistry of that particular
molecule and accordingly you design the
number of compounds
so there can be a case when we
we don't have like information about the
binding site
which is in the protein structure so we
have a tool to analyze that particular
binding pocket
using site map so height map is the name
of tool which helps you to
see what is basically present inside the
protein structure or inside the binding
process so this is what i was talking
about
so if you know what is inside the lock
so this is what the tool which helps you
to see what are the various properties
inside the lock and inside the protein
structure and once you get that
information
one can of course use it for the drug
designing then
next thing comes into like core hopping
so for hopping or scaffold hopping if
you have heard of
so this is the method which is very well
known uh
using the field of direct discovery by
industries
to generate a new structure of molecules
uh to skip the existing patterns even so
you can
basically look for various type of
course which are not exist
not existing in any reported patent and
in this way they can get to know about
novel molecules and they can patent it
and of course like they can a lot of
money out of it
so you can also perform various type of
energy analysis
on the proteins or protein ligand
complexes to understand it better like
which
functional group of protein is more
important for
binding to the receptor energetically
how favorable it is and that can be done
other than that basically there is one
revolutionary tool called
library enumeration so you can see like
you have a ligand which has
some basic structure which is constant
and one can generate basically millions
of compound just by single click
and performing various substitution at
the given point so
this is called as combinatorial
chemistry like uh
you don't need to draw each structure
one by one and generated lacks of
compound no that is not the smart way of
doing it
smart way of doing it is enumeration
automatic enumeration you just need to
tell the software okay i want uh
substitution at this particular position
and software will do all type of
possible substitution in it
so this is what is present with the
schrodinger suit and i must say it is
very much revolutionary in nature
other than that if you go for advanced
level of
molecular modeling and so you often
heard of the term molecular dynamic
simulations in which
so here we talk about actually
simulating the biological system
in biological environment how it looks
like
if you increase the temperature how it
is actually present inside the cell
inside the body
so we call it as a molecular dynamic
simulation and we can simulate it in a
real time
to see what are the conformational
changes which are occurring in the
protein means i was talking about the
structure of
lock so you can see like what are the
conformational changes which are
occurring in the lock
but here the lock is moving and you need
to know
like how it is moving so how
conformational changes are happening
how it affects the ligand binding and
not only that
you have a very another unique tool
which is called for
covalent type of docking so covalent
talking is nowadays
very much in the talk and very much
popular because
in case of kubit research there is a
protein called m pro and it has it is
reported with the covalent binder so
that is why it is in very well
known field now so far to study this
covalent binding and the phenomena you
can also study it using the schrodingers
we have module to do that and of course
if you go for higher level of studies
like you can of course refine the
x-ray structure based on the electron
densities and based on the
energetics of all those residues so for
that also we have a module you really
don't need to rely
everything on the experiments like we
can also do these things using
software and schrodinger so if you go
for a higher level of
molecular modeling studies the quantum
mechanics is the often hard term
so we can also do the quantum mechanical
calculations in shorting the suit to
understand the structure and chemistry
of
molecule then comes to the really really
advanced modules
and i must say this is a very popular
module in
industry because it is giving
revolutionary result
and the module name is water map even if
you see here
so this is basically a tool which helps
you to understand the thermodynamics of
water
so thermodynamics of water it is very um
the term which we heard in
plus two our plus two is the simple
thermodynamics like enthalpy entropy
changes and we can of course study those
enthalpic changes
whichever are happening in water and
when those are present inside the
binding pocket
and based on that you will come to know
about the very particular thing in
biology
and that particular thing is whether
your molecule
water is happy or unhappy when it is
present inside the pointing pocket so
simplest thing is you can see
here there are there is a protein
surface it's all
many water molecules which are
highlighted in sphere and those are
present inside the binding pocket
of the protein and you can see there are
few
spheres which are water molecule are in
red color and are in green color so
green color
is like a happy water molecule and red
color is
water molecule so once you identify
which one which candidate is happy which
one is unhappy
so the simple logic it is always easy to
dis replace unhappy one and it is
difficult to replace happy one so
overall idea is to replace the unhappy
one to design drug in better way
so this is what which helps us to
understand the water thermodynamics and
drug designing in better way
then here it comes the another module
called free energy perturbation fep plus
through which basically one can predict
the binding energy of ligand molecule
inside the protein structure
with the accuracy of 0.6 kilocalorie per
mole and it's very very rare
and i must say it is very much
revolutionary module which was by
schrodinger and you can see here in this
particular example like
with the help of software they could
replace basically
during the go like they could replace
the uh
they could adjust the another functional
group inside the ligand and because of
that functional group you can see it has
changed to
the halogen chloride because of that
chloride how much the binding energy
could change
and we are going to see all those things
in more detail in coming uh presentation
so don't worry about it at this point
just remember there are various things
which you can do it
with the schrodinger suit this is what
is the another example in lyo molecular
dynamic simulations like it tries to
modify the molecule inside the binding
and try to compute its binding energy
so this is what it comes with the small
molecule discovery so it was all about
uh studying or small molecules or doing
the small molecule discovery
but i another module which i was talking
about is the biologic suit means when
whenever you are working on proteins
antibodies
dna rna antigens
so if you are studying those kind of
things we
often call it as a biologics modeling so
we can do it with
schrodinger suit for example you can
design
antibodies you can humanize antibodies
you can study
antigen antibody interaction you can
develop a model of protein using
homology modeling
you can study various phenomena like
protein aggregations and what are the
properties of it
not only that you can also study how
protein protein binds together how
protein dna interacts how protein rna
interacts
those kind of things you can study with
the biologic suit
and not only that even in case of if you
want to modify the protein it comes
under the protein engineering
for example residue scanning like
alanine scanning cysteine scanning
by sulphide prediction identification of
reactive residues
to engineer your protein in better way
to improve its activity
so you can basically make a thermostable
protein for your
protein engineering stuff or to increase
its catalysis or to increase
stability so we can have those
applications also present in the
biologic suit
and when i said like discovery
informatics
so informatics whenever you work on
various projects
in the field of computer editor
designing in chemo informatics you come
up with the huge amount of data
and it is not only about generating data
but
it is the discovery is all about
analyzing that data and get the
information out of it
so this is what the discovery informatic
tools which help you to analyze the data
in real time
not only analyzing the data but consider
working live project which is going on
and 10 people are working on
single project at same time and
everybody is sitting across the globe
and still they can work it in a real
time all together they can do
all type of modifications at given point
and everybody
else will come to know about it so this
is what the type of
uh collaborations which we could make we
all
we call it as a basically project
management thing or this
enterprise discovery enterprise so
means everybody else come together and
they
start working on the same project and
this is not very much common in the
pharma industries and not only
industries
but even in academics you can have live
collaborations
where all scientists come together and
they work on the same
project at same time and they can get
more information out of it so this is
the way how discovery informatics helps
and not only that in disclosure
informatics is all about analyzing data
as i said so
you can do various type of clustering to
analyze the things
you will have like huge amount of data
when i say huge amount of data for the
hemo informatics way means you will have
huge discretize
huge amount of descriptors for many
billions of molecules
it finally interferes with the gigabytes
of data and you need a very powerful
tool
to analyze that data in various ways so
you can search it based on clustering
based on its fingerprint matching based
on these descriptors you can build
various type of models
we call it as qsr models and all those
things comes under this discovery
informatics to help you to
better understand the things then
things comes to the finally
visualization so visualization means
nothing but
the representation of data so at the end
you do your research project
you come up with a good results and
everything but it is always necessary
and very important thing is to present
that data in the nice way
so to to other to do that thing to
present the data in very nice way we
have a very powerful visualization tool
called
imode and with the help of that primal
tool like you can animate the thing you
can present it in the best way
so that it is understandable to uh
the researchers and this is also one of
the key point to get your
data published in good journals or to
get the recognition
by getting on the cover page of the
journal so
this is what the live example we have
for the visualization
or the data representation and then in
brief about material science so what
you can do with the materials and
material science so
you know like whatever is existing in
the world whatever you can see
is all materials it's all considered in
the material
and of course we can consider we can
study all those materials like carbon
nanotubes or
nanoparticles or any type of material
even batteries you can study it with the
schrodinger suite
so what things you can study it with the
schrodinger suit is you can study its
energetic you can build various type of
complexes like metal complexes
which has very weird kind of geometries
and you can screen basically various
type of structures which helps you to
understand it in better way for example
here is the virtual screening of battery
additives
means with the help of this software you
can find out which additive works better
in your battery
and not only battery like we can apply
these things also
in case of designing the better material
for rocket
which sustained in the space at
particular temperature particular
pressure
and all those things so you can look for
various type of
unexplored type of molecules
as your material for your particularly
for your particular study so for example
here is an example of
a film deposit deposition on the top of
some layer so you can also study that
so this is what it comes under
all molecular modeling so there is a
often
question people do ask like if i can do
the things with molecular docking itself
then why do i need that many problems
so so far if you remember like i have
presented like more than
uh 30 42 weeks so there are many such
tools which are necessary and why do we
need those tools
and basically who are using those tools
is it really worth to look for that many
tools
so my simple answer will be yes you need
that many tools because
the thing is very much complicated so if
you see
in the field of drug discovery the
overall process itself is very much
complicated and lengthy
so if you have heard of the process of
drug discovery from target
identification up to the
drug in market it takes around like 13
to 15 years of time and that's really
huge time yeah in that like 13 to 15
years like generation get change
and you really don't want to wait for
that very long that much long time
but we need to wait that's the critical
thing
we need to spend that much time on drug
discovery phases
and it's not only about time but it is
also about the money and so in onward
like time is always money
so as you spend more time it comes with
the
amount of salary for researchers many
researchers are involved in it their
time their money
so everything comes into picture and it
all end up with around 2 billion u.s
dollar
industry for each drug molecule and if
you calculate it in a
indian rupees it is almost 18 000 of
rupees it's a huge amount of money
so but if you see it critically there
are various phases of drug discovery if
you think smartly like where you can
work on so you can see there are blue
color regions and
orange color regions so here is the
orange color region which is
a more time consuming step for each step
we call it as a clinical phase mostly
clinical phase one phase two phase three
and basically as a researcher you can't
really do anything
much in this clinical phase because
whenever a molecule gets put into
clinical phase
it's a single drug molecule which we
administer
in the patients and study its properties
but we can't really modify that molecule
we can't play with that molecule because
what we can do as a researcher is what
clinical scientists do they can they
observe the properties they observe what
effect
that particular molecule is uh giving us
in the body
that's it means they can only observe
the thing but they can't play with the
molecule
but if you see smartly there is an
initial phase of drug discovery which
spans for around six to seven years of
time
out of 13 to 15 years so you can see
like it all
comes up with the initial phases where
you perform high throughput virtual
screening you
identify the target you identify the
molecule you optimize that one
in short like you can play with the
particular molecule you can optimize it
you can perform various substitution
check its properties
and once it is all done you end up with
the one molecule
you put it into clinical trial and
that's it afterwards like human can only
analyze all uh
only look for the things which molecule
does with our body
but the researchers can play initial
its role in initial phase of drug
discovery so with the help of computers
like we can work on that initial phase
at various steps and we try to reduce
the number of
animal studies we try to maybe as many
as possible number of molecules to
identify the best molecule out of it
and to work on this particular initial
phase of drug discovery here the
software comes into picture
and here that many tools comes into
picture like with the help of
that many tools you can study all type
of millions of compounds
thoroughly to get the best result so
this is what the necessary thing which
we need to do
to reduce the time scale of drug
discovery
to give the better drug as a output
and why it is like as such it is very
much complicated as i said and why do
you need that many tools
because it's very much complicated and
to understand its complexity you need to
understand the thing
it is really really complicated so here
is the example
where you can have various drug
molecules and there are various number
of properties which we need to
consider whenever you design a drug
molecule like it should have
good binding it should have good potency
not only that you should have good form
of kinetic properties
it should have good metabolic profile it
should have good solubility and many
other thing it should not have any
toxicity
so there are many aspects and i would
say there are hundreds of such aspects
which you need to consider while
designing a molecule
and the overall drug discovery is
identifying about the star molecule
which comes
under all aspects and it should satisfy
all those criteria
so finding this star molecule is really
really really difficult and even i would
say it is
harder than the rocket science because
rocket science also follows the laws of
physics and if you project the rocket
we go in the right direction but if you
consider the same thing in
case of biological system when you put
drug molecule inside the body you never
know how it is going to be affected
so we can't have any control on it just
like once you take the tablet you don't
have any control on it like where it
goes where it binds what effect it will
show
it can show any type of effect and with
the help of computers
the drug discovery scientist basically
our duty is to manage
all those properties in this particular
stock market
that is the reason i hope you got the
complexity of it
so the thing is one can get through all
those
things with the simple logic that if you
test more number of compounds
the chances is better to get the good
molecule as the output
and this good number thing like 10 20
years before
that people used to synthesize like 2000
molecules
because that was the capacity of any
synthetic chemist
and out of which like they could end up
with the one molecule in clinical trials
and eventually if that get fails the
whole project get down
but now with the help of advanced
computational modeling we have softwares
we can basically screen
not only thousands but billions of such
compounds i would say hundred billions
of
compounds you can screen it with compute
with the help of computers rapidly fast
and with the accurate predictions
and when we apply this all computational
filter you need the chances of
getting a good molecule out of it is
huge
and again like once you get that
molecule as
output with with that huge chances the
chances of failure
becomes less but still but the still
like you know whenever you put molecules
in clinical trial you never know like
whether it will pass or fail
but we can predict all those properties
in an early stage
of drug discovery to reduce that loss so
this is what the important thing which
we need to always consider as a
discovery scientist
and here i would just like to give you a
brief introduction on
so i was talking about all those things
how how this software helps and
one should go what are the things one
should go with and what are the ideal
thing we should consider
but this is what what actually happened
so in schrodinger we work on a project
called
acetyl coenzyme a for carboxylase
inhibitor design
along with the numbers therapeutics
which is again
contract research and organization so
schrodinger and nimbus get collaborated
and they
they started working on the project
called acc and this is what the project
was mentioned by mr jaguar initial
presentation
so they got the success by using all
type of computational methods and they
got
the molecule with ind approval within a
span of 16 months if you see this
line on bottom so it's the time scale
like the ident they generated various
type of
molecules initially they use
computational screening not only
computational but
experimental screening on selected
compound they optimize the heat molecule
and finally they got the
lead molecules and they filed for india
and whole process took only 16 months of
time and this is not even 1.5
years of time you can see and initially
we were talking
about that initial phase of drug
discovery was for
six to seven years and now we have
reduced with the help of computational
tools
with just 16 months and that is called
as acceleration of drug discovery
that is called as saving of money not
only money saving of time
so in this way we can accelerate the
process and the best example is
in front of you like kobe drugs we have
so this is what is the example of
accelerated drug discovery they could
screen the various molecules
using drug repurposing and you got
rendezvous as a output
against the covalent and this is what
people are using so
if what happens because of computational
power and not only computational power
but the scientists from various
disciplines when they all come together
and work rationally
rationally is the important word here if
they work rationally
with the help of all tools they could
get successfully instituted
and this was the breakthrough like when
schrodinger got
success with this particular molecule
within span of 16 months
they sold this complete project to
gilead pharma
and it was for 1.2 billion they made
huge money out of it
so they showed to the drug discovery
industry like this is how one could
efficiently use the software to
develop a drug uh against the
target so this was the successful
example and this successful example will
be again
explained in detail in upcoming
presentations so don't worry about
it just keep in mind that we have
success story and
right now this particular molecule is in
phase 2 clinical trial and
it is along with the numbers
therapeutics
so in this way like with schrodinger
there were
there are many such projects which are
going on and many such projects are in
advanced stage and
not only with that even with indian
pharma industry this is the spark spark
is the subsidiary of sun pharma which is
the indian foreign industry like uh even
we collaborated with that and
the project is going on successfully so
i think at this point i just stopped
here i i hope you everybody got the
brief idea about
the modules that asked which you can do
with the schrodinger suit
and at this point you just need to know
like there are various tasks we need to
do but
afterwards we will have enough time to
discuss on each task
in upcoming presentations and we are
also going to conduct a workshop
for two days here in this particular
course and in that two days we will
try to see many modules and try to
actually work on the schrodinger suit
and
that time you will really understand the
things in better way
you will get actual hands on uh on the
software you will be able to understand
the things
so with this uh i would like to say
thank you to all of you
and i would like to acknowledge my team
so we are the team of
uh 10 people who are there in the
bangalore office and we are working
around the clock to help you out
the user of sharing the suit to provide
guidance and all type of support
so so far you have heard uh mr raguranos
he's the vice president of schwingler's
office here
but other than that in the upcoming
session you will get chance to hear
uh dr pritish bhatt is the principal
scientist
mr vinody and dr koshi in upcoming
sessions so we are all
there and we have a technical team
headed by mr kishore who helps you to
basically install that software and
understand its technicality
and our business development officer
michelle young she will be also talking
to you in upcoming
sessions to uh to tell you about the
how to access the software how you can
get the free version of software and
so with this i think my sinclair thanks
to all of you for joining the
this particular session and listening
the presentation carefully
and again here is my email id which is
um
in case of any queries you can of course
write it to me
please feel free to do it and now at
this point i would like to open the
session for questions and
i would also say thanks to the organizer
for giving me
if you can share the details on software
evaluation
that would be helpful many questions
were there on that
yeah sure let me check the screen again
uh is it possible that i can share that
information
yes thank you very much for rescuing me
uh yeah you are the best person to talk
about it and
i would really like to request
right um so um hi everyone
i just wanted to to introduce myself
i think dr pacho already introduced me
i'm shelby
and i'm the account manager for the
academic institutions in india
um so if you'd like to procure the
software
or if you'd like to go for an evaluation
on a trial version
you can contact me so our evaluation
license
is generally for one month and it comes
with full support
for installation online training
discussion and assistance related to
your research work
um also if you would like to publish one
paper using your
your evaluation license if you have
enough data
we also uh let you publish one paper
and uh so if there's any question please
let me know
i also urge you to please go visit our
website
um and also please try to
request the website account in order
to get any future notification for uh
you know any upcoming events
i'll share you all the information as
well all the links
thank you so much elvia ma now i would
like to take you
all through the registration process
uh so cinelika before the hello everyone
before the
registration process there were a few
technical questions as well
uh which were asked before so can you
address them
why are you i guess yes
i'll just take these questions first
then
so aditya is asking if some water
molecule is unhappy inside the protein
okay then probably it will not retain
for a long time in the protein
during the simulation is it correct
yeah it's absolutely correct uh it will
not stay
for long time but uh with the help of
software we need
uh it is advisable to know that
which is
okay and the next question is in free
energy calculation how did you tackle
the entropy calculation
yeah so it considers entropy also when
we calculate the free energy
of course entropy is always there in the
system so
we need to consider if you don't
consider entropy then
you will get the not really good results
of it
we need to consider and this schrodinger
includes the recent
ff of protein and nucleic acid
force field yeah so schrodinger has
its proprietary forestry which is found
as fbls4
and that is kind of robust force field
which we have which is applicable to
every type of molecule not only protein
not only small molecules not only metal
ligand complexes
but you can also have it for materials
dnas rnas
nanoparticles everything i would i'm
saying everything
exists in the atoms
okay so thank you i hope this answer
your questions
do you have any other question you can
announce yourself and ask
okay i think his questions are here but
i don't have one question so uh
virtual is there something for protein
protein interaction and like their
stimulation or something like that
to understand uh that aspect of vaccine
design for example
yes of course that's very generic term
protein protein interaction
and we do have as i said in biologic
suit we do have all this stuff to
understand protein protein antibody
antigen
protein dna protein rna studies
okay thank you i got them asked
if target protein more than one for
disease management then how to proceed
so in the field of molecular modeling of
course you can put
if you know like there are more than one
target then you can
perform like virtual screening or
molecular talking to understand
that yeah the molecule of your interface
is able to bind
to that particular targets that can be
multiple targets it's under poly
pharmacology
so we can use this techniques to
understand
that polyphenol
okay so thank you and rita to your
question you can contact shelby our mom
and then ask her how to load your own
data how to use the tool to load your
own data
now let me just take you through the
registration process
so i would be sharing the link here here
in the chat as well
so to register yourself for the upcoming
program of chem informatics or
biomedical drug discovery you need to go
here and start your
application and then choose the level
which you would like to opt for
and proceed further to know more about
the program
you can also go through this video here
and learn more about the program and the
session details
on the page itself so we have all the
details here on
which date what session would be covered
and what would be the details of the
session
and also we would be shortly uploading
the zoom
links over here so it would be very easy
for those people who have registered
themselves for the program
to join the program and also they would
get the recordings of each and every
session
if you have any doubts you can contact
me at marketing at the rate pine dot bio
and if anyone wants to ask something
then they can do so we can
we can leave the mic open for queries
now
so there's a question about from altaf
that
if they can receive the recording of
this session
yes they will receive the recording of
the of the session i would be sending
out the recording to everyone
okay then it was great to have you all
here and if you have any doubts then
dr prajwal has shared his mail id too
for technical doubts on schrodinger and
if you want to register yourself and if
you are facing any sort of issues you
can mail me at marketing at the
ratepine.bio
i leave my id in the chat box
or you can also contact doctor mohit at
mohit at the refine dot bio
thank you so much everyone for attending
uh thank you sonalika uh i would like to
thank
uh hey guys this is sujit from former
doctors i would like to thank
schrodinger entire team
for giving uh such an opportunity to
everyone to learn about all this drug
discovery and about schrodinger
thank you schroedinger team and thank
you so much and thank you all
participants
for participating for participating into
this webinar
thank you guys thank you so much dr
sujeeth
okay then by everyone we would be
looking forward to your participation in
the program and then we can learn more
from the
uh schrodinger team and the other the
other collaborators as well
thank you so much
thank you very much
thank you thank you dr prajwal it was an
amazing presentation and looking forward
to learn from
uh your you during the entire program
yes indeed sure thank you
thank you
you